[Musique]
et cette invité aujourd'hui c'est vous
Thomas Pernet bonjour bonjour bienvenue
sur ce plateau mais merci à vous d'être
là vous êtes journaliste spécialiste des
têtes couronnées dans l'hebdo de
référence ici en France point de vue
votre dernier livre s'appelle il est de
circonstances Elisabeth II les chapeaux
de la couronne il est sorti aux éditions
EPA on le disait à l'instant c'est une
semaine deuil qui commence au
Royaume-Uni à 4 jours après le décès
d'Elisabeth II on va y revenir dans un
instant mais je voudrais qu'on vienne
sur quelques images fortes du week-end
si vous le voulez bien d'abord bien sûr
l'image de cette foule immense qui
accompagnait pendant des heures le
cortège funéraire d'Élisabeth II de
Balmoral à Édimbourg en Écosse qu'est-ce
qu'il y avait entre les Écossais et leur
reine particulier il y en a beaucoup
parlé bien sûr des vérités
d'indépendance de l'Ecosse mais
néanmoins l'Écosse était cher au cœur
d'Elizabeth de sa mère était écossaise
elle y passait toutes ses vacances le
château de Balmoral c'est un peu une des
résidences préférées de la reine avec
Windsor et avec le Britannia qui
aujourd'hui n'est plus en activité le
yacht royal qui qui naviguer toutes les
mers du monde jusque dans les années 90
et bien sûr alors les Écossais sont
heureux parce qu'ils ont perdu une
souveraine mais fier malgré tout qu'elle
se soit éteinte en Écosse et on l'a bien
vu moi j'ai été frappé notamment sur les
images que vous montrez à votre
téléspectateur par ces foules qui
attendaient juste au bord de la route on
a quand même traversé des territoires
qui sont quand même très peu habités
puis il y a bien sûr et d'un bourg et
quand le corbillard est passé on a eu
d'abord ce silence ce respect et puis
ces applaudissements c'était très beau
alors expliquez-nous vous l'avez évoqué
pour les républicains que nous sommes
comment cohabitent ces velléités
d'indépendance et cette attachement à la
monarchie de la part des Écossais vous
savez le Royaume-Uni c'est très complexe
et pour nous Français en effet c'est
compliqué d'ailleurs on dit souvent le
roi d'Angleterre ou la reine
d'Angleterre le roi du Royaume-Uni la
reine du Royaume-Uni c'est quatre
nations qui coexistent au sein d'un même
pays et puis au-delà la reine et
aujourd'hui le roi Charles III sont
souverains de 15 pays le Canada
l'Australie la Nouvelle-Zélande et j'en
passe on dit souvent et on a raison que
les indépendantistes sont forts en
Écosse mais c'est pas parce que si un
jour j'en sais rien je fais de la
politique fiction une mycoses devenir
indépendante Charles III n'en serait pas
encore le roi on peut très bien être roi
des cosses d'une Écosse indépendante et
de et de et de garder finalement les
Windsor sur le trône je pense que que
oui la couronne fait partie du ciment de
ce pays Élisabeth de la prouvé reste à
savoir si Charles III bien sûr n'est pas
aujourd'hui aussi populaire que sa mère
peut maintenir le pays du moins
maintenir sa cohésion par exemple pour
le pour le
cas très écossaise vous l'avez dit un
charlot 3 les petits lottants lui dont
on dit qu'il est très anglais finalement
je pense que Charles III va de toute
manière être dans l'héritage de sa mère
et oui peut-être que il est le plus
anglais de des Princes c'est un homme
qui malgré tout est aussi très Gallois
on avait été étonné il a porté ce type
de Prince de Galles en 69 quand il est
investi couronné prince de Galles il
fait son discours en gallois c'est très
nouveau donc c'est un homme qui a quand
même conscience de la diversité des
nations de son pays je pense que malgré
tout il va nous le montrer notamment en
venant à Édimbourg aujourd'hui il est
aussi écossette cœur c'est son rôle
d'ailleurs c'est pas seulement que les
les sentiments et il sera aussi écossé
que sa mère c'est vrai que la célèbre
série qui est revenue sur l'histoire de
la Couronne britannique avait raconté
assez bien la difficulté que ça avait
été pour lui de prononcer ce discours en
gallois alors il est roi depuis le décès
de sa mère officiellement proclamé
samedi dernier alors vous me direz que
jusqu'ici il a eu assez peu l'occasion
de faire des faux pas mais est-ce qu'on
a eu quelques éléments de la façon de la
couleur du lexique que va être son règne
je crois que le premier discours
enregistré a montré déjà le style
Charles III c'est-à-dire un style bien
sûr solennelle c'est un roi et le monde
est heureux de voir ce roi et les
Français aussi parce que vous savez nous
en France on est un peu resté bloqué
dans les années 90 à la mort de Diana
pauvre Diana c'est vrai c'était un
terrible drame le méchant Charles
l'infâme Kamila on a eu du mal à évoluer
la reine sans cœur la reine ça allait
mieux on adore la reine mais Charles et
Camilla c'était compliqué entre temps de
l'eau a coulé sous les ponts Charles est
remonté dans les sondages Camila aussi
elle est devenue bien sûr duchesse de
Cornouaille aujourd'hui elle est Rennes
et aujourd'hui on voit quand même un
couple
uni sur le trône qui aurait pu penser
encore quelques mois quelques années
qu'un jour Camila serait reine et
Charles III montre déjà sa patte en
étant peut-être plus humain moi j'étais
aussi frappé de voir quand ils sont
arrivés à Buckingham comment ils sont
allés à la rencontre des gens touchent
beaucoup plus facilement donc il va y
avoir cette pâte là alors bien sûr vous
le disiez votre corres on le disait pour
l'instant on n'a pas encore eu trop le
temps de faire des faux pas il y a quand
même eu une image pendant la
proclamation il rejette l'encrier où
tout le monde se dit ouh là ce monsieur
a quand même été élevé par voilà
compliqué vous devez signer les papiers
je sais pas moi qui vais lui jeter la
pierre j'ai jamais été roi et
l'événement est grave je pense que on va
voir une monarchie encore plus humaine
même si la reine depuis 20 ans avait
montré déjà un visage plus souriant plus
humain et c'est aussi ça qui a fait son
grand retour son royal come-back alors
on a beaucoup dit de Charles que c'était
un hypersensible avec ça vient le fait
de dire les choses là où effectivement
sa mère était plutôt connue pour sa
capacité son talent à se contenir un roi
du Royaume-Uni n'est pas censé dire les
choses en l'occurrence qu'est-ce que ça
peut donner avec Charles ah oui alors il
y a deux façons d'y aller chose il y a
dire les choses l'émotion moi dans le
message quand il dit ma chère maman au
moment où tu commences ton voyage vers
mon cher papa on dit les sentiments là
où vous avez raison c'est qu'on ne dit
pas les choses institutionnellement
parlant notamment sur la vie politique
on ne dit on ne dit rien notamment et
Charles même sans parler de politique
c'est-à-dire soutenir quelle partie par
rapport à quelle partie c'est quand même
un homme qui aime bien s'exprimer qui
est volontaire il a gassé pendant des
décennies les membres du gouvernement
d'envoyant des petits mémos les célèbres
mémos du prince Charles d'ailleurs un
jour malgré Thatcher pas vous ce qui est
quand même le ramener un peu à son rôle
institutionnel aujourd'hui il va falloir
qu'il apprenne à se taire ça va pas être
facile sur des secteurs des domaines des
combats qui lui tiennent à cœur
notamment l'écologie mais rappelons que
il fallait bien qu'il qu'il se trouve
une place un rôle pendant cette longue
attente de Prince de Galles puis
maintenant il y a un nouveau prince de
Galles qui va reprendre aussi ses
combats notamment le combat pour la
planète le prince William qui a lancé un
prix pour la planète il y a deux ans on
va certainement reprendre les
institutions les oeuvres caritatives de
Charles et lui Charles il doit reprendre
ce silence Royal porter cette couronne
et la porter avec dignité avec
professionnelle professionnalisme il va
le faire il va le faire très très bien
mais en effet en étant peut-être un peu
moins volontaire dans dans ces prises de
parole à propos du nouveau prince de
Galles William donc ça a été l'une des
l'une des images du week-end Les Quatre
Fantastiques
réunis pour la première fois depuis deux
ans ces deux couples dont on dit qu'il
ne se parle plus réconciliation de
façade qu'est-ce que vous en pensez
alors c'est l'un des secrets des tas les
mieux gardés en ce moment on espère tous
que c'est pas une réconciliation de
façade alors il est vrai que quand on
regarde ces images on voit pas sur une
chaleur humaine incroyable non mais
malgré tout c'est un premier pas et
c'était très important vous savez là on
va vivre des émotions diverses et ça
commence et d'avoir le choc il y a la
peine et puis aussi la joie moi dans ces
images je vois la joie des gens de
retrouver ces deux frères parce que bien
sûr les Britanniques le monde entier n'a
connu que Elisabeth II maison aussi
grandi vu grandir ces deux princes qui
sont liés à un destin commun tragique
par la perte de leur mère et de les
retrouver c'est très important et puis
on voit quand même que ces deux couples
ont deux styles différents Meghan Markle
elle est américaine on peut dire qu'elle
est comédienne est-ce que c'est une
façon de dire qu'elle est insincerge
j'en sais rien moi je donc cette jeune
femme aussi beaucoup de talents elle
touche les gens les prend dans les bras
on est encore dans une autre dimension
ça ça fait du bien et c'est le rôle de
la monarchie finalement il y a nous on a
peut-être un peu du mal à l'imaginer on
est passionné ébahi on adore la pompe le
folklore mais il y a aussi une charge
émotionnelle on vit avec eux on a besoin
de les voir on avait besoin de voir le
visage du roi quand il est descendu de
l'avion qui le ramenait d’aberdine il y
a une dimension presque dans la chair
tactile et c'est leur job ils doivent
être achevés de la nation quand la
nation s'ouvre ou aussi vivre avec eux
des moments heureux qu'est-ce que les
mariages royaux si ce n'est aussi des
grands moments de communion qu'est-ce
que vont être les funérailles de de la
Reine Elizabeth si c'était un grand
moment de deuil national à vivre
ensemble dans un instant un sujet sur
lequel j'aimerais bien avoir votre
éclairage encore une fois nous expliquer
à nous qui ne sommes pas britanniques
comment est-ce qualifié ce moment que
ville Royaume-Uni vous diriez vous
lisiez tout à l'heure on sent les gens à
la fois tristes sincèrement triste et à
la fois heureux de voir cette continuité
c'est une forme de quoi de bouleverse
vraiment serein je pense qu'il y a même
quelque chose presque
d'entreprenologique c'est un rythme de
passage c'est c'est ce qui va être
incroyable c'est de voir les foules et
elles vont être nombreuses qui vont se
presser pour juste passer devant le
cercueil d'Elizabeth II un cercueil qui
sera
offert presque au public à partir de
mercredi dans Westminster Hall les
autorités ont déjà prévenu que ce serait
24 heures sur 24 pour la reine mère
décédé en 2002 il y avait 200 à 300 000
personnes qui s'étaient pressées mais là
on va on va voir des foules immenses on
compare ça avec la mort de Diana et le
choc qui a été Diana c'est un peu
différent parce que Diana était bien sûr
jeune personne ne s'attendait à son
décès là malgré tout c'est tout un pays
qui tourne une page et c'est pas facile
de tourner la page même s'il a aussi on
se projette dans l'avenir c'est j'aime
pas faire de la psychanalyse de comptoir
mais malgré tout il y a quelque chose
qui touche vraiment à l'intime à notre
relation à la mort à notre relation à
l'histoire et même nous on est peut-être
républicain ça serait improbable d'avoir
une famille royal en France après deux
siècles de révolution française mais
regardez comme ça nous passionne
regardez comme on en parle depuis quatre
jours et regardez comme sur votre
antenne et sur les autres on va
continuer en parler ça touche à quelque
chose de très intime dans chacun d'entre
nous en chacun d'entre nous et on le vit
collectivement Elisabeth den était pas
seulement souveraine du Royaume-Uni
était 14 autres pays sur lequel aérien
elle était la grand-mère
l'arrière-grand-mère du monde et bien on
dit au revoir aussi à cet
arrière-grand-mère aujourd'hui alors à
partir de mercredi le cercueil sera
effectivement exposé à Londres à partir
d'aujourd'hui cet après-midi à la
cathédrale Saint-Gilles à Édimbourg vous
le disiez on attend sans doute en Écosse
puis en Angleterre quoi des centaines de
milliers de personnes avant donc lundi
prochain on aura l'occasion d'en
reparler bien sûr mais l'apothéose quoi
les funérailles du siècle oui les
funérailles qui vont être je sais même
pas comment les qualifier tous les chefs
d'État vont venir Joe Biden l'a dit
l'Empereur du Japon Naruto va faire le
déplacement quasiment jamais du Japon
beaucoup moins c'est une monarchie qui
est très particulière en effet qui est
très fermé sur elle-même mais comment ne
pas être au funérailles d'une légende
enfin il y a déjà eu des déclarations on
a appris à vérifier que que
urini hélicoptère ni jet privé parce que
le l'espace aérien va être tellement
surchargé on va voir tous ces chefs
d'État qui vont arriver en bus à
Westminster comment gérer le bal des
voitures diplomatiques des dignitaires
et puis moi j'attends de voir sur tout
l'émotion à Londres enfin j'ai la chance
de partir à Londres dans quelques heures
ça va être un moment incroyable là aussi
bien sûr un moment de deuil et puis un
moment où on a besoin d'être ensemble
mais la télévision mais pour ceux qui
peuvent faire le déplacement pour des
Britanniques qui vont faire des
centaines de kilomètres qui soit au Pays
de Galles dans le nord de l'Angleterre
en Écosse c'est ses besoins de vivre les
choses ensemble parce que au-delà de la
pompe au delà du respect il y a toujours
cette émotion collective qu'on a envie
de partager ensemble ben écoutez merci
beaucoup d'être venu à nous en parler ce
matin donc le début d'une semaine de
deuil qui commence et jusqu'à donc
effectivement c'est funérailles lundi
prochain à Londres dont vous serez on
vous écoutera et on vous dira pour ma
planète notamment donc dans point de vue
je rappelle le titre de votre dernier
livre Elisabeth II les chapeaux de la
Couronne qui est sorti aux éditions EPA
merci encore